Georgia Tech and Emory University and
she has an appointment that places these
professors I met before engineering
she was praying originally as an
engineer with her student in
neuroscience and works as the title
suggests on neuro mechanics of sensory
control right okay I want to thank the
organizers for for having me here and as
this sounds very loud to me you like it
loud and I I studied neural control of
movement and I wanted to talk a little
bit about give you some background and
the what I am really interested in which
is the interaction between the nervous
system and the body that it controls and
this is a two-way interaction I have
task-specific plasticity here because
the brain changes the body and that and
the body changes the brain so a little
bit about what I I'm interested in first
I study as a model of sensory motor
control the control of balance and so
the center panel is what oops
go back putting at the wrong place okay
so the center panel here has been what
I've been studying for a long time which
is how we stand up which is sounds
pretty boring but actually is quite
interesting and involves multiple nested
loops and time delays and sort of the
mechanics of falling or trying not to
fall and from there we are now expanding
sort of down to the level of what is
this sensory encoding and
neuromodulation that affects the sort of
flexibility and and richness that we see
in in the control of balance both from a
multi-sensory integration side as well
as mostly I focus on the control of the
multiple muscles that allow you to stand
up and then more more recently we're
also recording from brain potentials
during perturbations to balance looking
for signals of error --air assessment
and looking at differences in perception
and we study healthy individuals as well
as people with disorders of the nervous
system that allow us to sort of do
natural experiments on what happens when
parts of the nervous system fail and the
and the brain and body compensate for
that so the primary paradigm that that I
use is putting animals or people on a
moving platform and there's pulling the
rug out from under them okay so you can
see I've done this to two cats to a
person and we have think these all run
automatically some some musculoskeletal
simulations of this that's a baby
familiar we do not protect the flamingos
but we'd be on
I stand on one leg and principals we've
identified sort of generalized
principles about how these diverse
behaviors work and they also generalize
to sort of walk to you it's through the
HDMI and and those principles extend to
more challenging behaviors walking this
is a ballet dancer from the Atlanta
ballet walking across the beam and this
is a Georgia Tech students doing the
same thing but but not very well so I'm
interested in the diversity of all these
things and what are the the binding
principles for how how these behaviors
are achieved okay so turn the volume off
there's no more fight okay so I became
interested in a movement as an undergrad
but I was a mechanical engineer so
really cared about how we move from a
from a mechanical standpoint and so you
know depending on who you ask a
neurobiologist will say that the you
know the brain controls the body a bio
mechanist will say well the body has its
own dynamics and and the brain can only
make suggestions and just to highlight
what the differences in these ways of
thinking are from a neuroscience
perspective it's like a huge brain and
neural a paradise and I'm gonna make a
decision to move then I'm gonna activate
all of these things whoops I don't like
this okay all of these complex neural
circuits downstream and then and then we
move and most neuroscience studies at
least when I came into the field ended
with looking at the electrical patterns
of motor neuron activity and inferring a
movement okay I I came at it from the
opposite direction where I saw these
really awesome passive walking machines
that appear to walk with no this has no
actuation as and it just walks down a
slope so it could transform
gravitational potential energy into a
motion that looks a lot like human
walking and so I thought you know we
could just understand these very complex
mechanics then we should we should
understand how the brain controls
walking okay so maybe that was a bit
naive but um which it was uh-huh but two
interesting viewpoints that I would like
to sort of bring together and I was
talking to Andy Rowena who is a
theoretical mechanics person who studies
a lot of movements and he said well this
mechanics is hard and the control is
sort of trivial and so it's not
interesting now he has ten years later
recanted and now he thinks that control
is everything and and I said but you
know Andy why is it that you know so
first first of all this thing to walk is
making it walk is really hard okay you
got to get the mechanics right and then
it's like thousand trials of getting the
initial conditions right and then if you
blow on it it falls over okay so and I
said why is it that if I saw you even if
you had the same biomechanics that I
would be able to recognize the way that
you walk from across the quad and even
if you know your evil doppelganger had
the same biomechanics I probably would
be able to tell the difference and this
is one of those sort of unanswered
questions and he said I'm gonna show you
something it'll it's gonna change your
life and what it was was a simulation
from a computer scientist Karen Lu who
whose fortunately now at Georgia Tech
who did some recordings of people moving
and then did some inverse optimization
extracted some parameters of how you
might control joint torques differently
and then synthesized new movements that
were not actually measured and so
happens if I do this at the computer
nope that's not it
and she was able to pull out synthesized
movements with different keys movement
styles result they swing their right
arms mute that character my computer's
mute but i can't mute the volume i'm
gonna have to talk over that but so when
they recorded people walking sad or
happy they were not carrying a weight
and then she was able to synthesize
people walking said are happy with the
weight and you could see that this thing
is executed in in different ways just
because i put some constraints in how
the torques at the the joints were
actually put together and based on some
of the work we've done even for
predicting how patients move it's it's
now been shown to be important to
actually consider individualized
patterns of movements which is to say
there is not the way that we walk okay
so if we're looking for some the pattern
of muscle activity we're not going to
find it and that's in fact what we see
we talked about variability a lot so so
this is i put up a bunch of papers that
people may be interested in but this
hillel shell has been very influential
in in my thinking where you know the the
adaptive behavior that we see really
emerges from these interactions between
the brain the body and the environment
and one of the things we've we've seen
over the you know there's the bath
complexity of the nervous system and
they were done that see and what what
happens is you know mainly when we
simulate the body in the environment it
doesn't look at all like what we do when
we walk basically you try to run
simulations and it basically crumbles
and it falls down okay same thing with
neural systems most of the time they
don't if you don't have the parameters
right they don't act like biological
systems and and what we find though is
that you know there's a there's a huge
set like if we actually specify behavior
we can actually reduce the set of sort
of behaviors or solutions that we
that are sort of neuro mechanically
feasible that could produce a behavior
but then when we look at each individual
in each instance in time we're actually
going to see one one of many possible
solutions and that's been seen we see it
in the mechanical system and this has
been known in in neural systems where
the asteroid Prinze did a sort of a
brute-force sweep of parameters and a
very simple circuit here for a digestion
and a crab and found that you could get
good enough behavior from lots of
different parameters and also this idea
that if I took the average set of
conductances from a neuron and put it
into a model that it wouldn't actually
spike but if I took the very specific
numbers that I got from each animal then
it actually would produce behavior so
the structure the relationships between
all the parts that we see matter both at
at the neural level and at the
musculoskeletal level so there's all
kinds of behaviors we you know we don't
we can do but but we don't do and one of
the things that was very influential for
me when when I actually was an undergrad
here at Berkeley working with Bob full
and we were studying cockroach
locomotion and what he found was that
there's there's sort of uh you can have
a two four or six or eight legged animal
and come up with a basic principle about
how it how it moves and come up with
this template of a spring and a mass
model for coordinating the limbs and it
turns out that you know the two four or
six or eight legs these animals look
very similar in the overall ground
reaction forces with the same and then
and that mark raybert was actually using
these principles to make robots that
moved in if he could figure out how to
do it with one leg then he could do two
and then he could do four and and he of
course as the founder of Boston Dynamics
and they make the you know the most
versatile robots arguably out there
unfortunately we don't know
what the secret sauce is and it's robots
so but this is something that very much
stuck with me of how do we find
generalizing principles to coordinate
all of these objects sorry all of these
body parts - you know achieve similar
goals and that led me down the path
where you know what I study now is these
principles of hierarchy and modularity
and sensory motor control which I say
are necessary for robustness for
flexibility and and that necessarily
lead to the fact that we we are all
slightly different from from each other
so I'll talk about this a little bit
more so my yeah so I have three parts to
the talk first by-product meaning so I
think that individuality comes from a
number of adaptive processes on
different time skills across evolution
across your lifespan and even for a
moment to moment when we perform tasks
and I'll explain that a little bit more
but at the end okay so all right so
first I'm going to make it try and make
a case that sensory motor control is
sort of a very canonical decision-making
process that nervous systems do that can
provide insight for other things that we
think are more abstract like cognitive
cognitive tasks because in general
they're trying to achieve you're trying
to achieve some goal and more
importantly for brains trying to
coordinate a system in different ways to
do different tasks so you have one
system and you want to be a generalist
right so and then I'll talk sort of a
background sort of a historical look at
hierarchical neural systems for control
of
movement and since I'm interested and
gate will focus on on locomotion and
balance and then I'll tell you a little
bit about some of the research that
we've done on these sort of what happens
when you look at the nervous system
interacting with the body and how some
principles of modularity become
important to facilitate the robustness
of our movements okay so first I think
you know why do we have brains if you if
you want to you can look at this video
from Dan walpert who says that brains
are just there to make us move and and
in a proximate sense and and a distal
sense we see nervous systems evolve when
animals have to move and this is a
tourniquet this is like this see animal
has 100 neurons so it's actually less
than C elegans and then it has to swim
around in this environment unmapped
environment and find a place to land and
it has to sense the environment and then
and make decisions and then when it
finds a place it sits and attaches to
iraq and the neurons responsible for you
know it's swimming around are disappear
they're digested it does still have
neurons to allow it to feed and in fact
we also have lots of neurons in our gut
that allow us to move food around and
digest and that's pretty I'm not gonna
really talk about it but you can look at
the little brain but what what is
similar about sort of a motor you know
what do I call a decision and ultimately
if we're gonna do neural processing it's
to make decisions about what we should
do you know we have to interpret
ambiguous sensory information if since
the same input was always needed to sit
produce the same output you would just
build it into a mechanical system
because neurons are costly and slow you
have to coordinate multiple body parts
and in in different ways again if I if
it was just a mechanism that worked then
I would just build a mechanism to do
that I wouldn't have to have a nervous
system and then for adaptability you can
weigh different costs and constraints at
different times and and adapt that
allows you to adapt to different
behavioral contexts and it's just that
when we when we look at movement we
think of as very objective and physical
and that there must be a solution that's
you know I spent first half of my career
trying to find that solution and I could
not find it I'm still convincing my
field that it's not a you know objective
and and you can argue that everything
else also in some way results in a
movement the cognitive emotional brain
farms of this escape right escapes
induces fear and helps you run away from
things faster and you'll see the very
simple animals have very complex
structures like a flea like just
releases energy and it's leg but it's
leg can only jump and so those types of
animals tend to have very simple not
command neurons that just evoke a
behavior but they're not very very
flexible so there's decisions to be made
both on the sensory side the motor side
and then what should I be doing right
now all right so this is a paper that
came out and just caused some trouble
ooh it co-signed this here but
neuroscience needs behavior and they
here pre presented what Wolfgang
presented yesterday this idea from our
that there are three sort of levels that
we can you know think about animals
moving our brains functioning which is
you know what's what's the problem that
you're trying to solve what are the
rules and then what are the what's the
implementation and so we really need to
think about it behavior and what what
are we trying to shape why are we
spending all this energy making neurons
fire
and then are there other principles
because these implementations tend to be
slightly varying from you know one
person to the next one one animal to the
next so getting these principles in the
middle is really important all right so
I'm now gonna give you an example of
we've talked about the cortex a lot and
I'm going to talk about what the cortex
is not needed for this is very you might
say the spinal cord this is a spine
alized frog and it has to make a motor
decision of how should I move my limb
and you can do an experiment where you
put a piece little acid or irritant on
the skin so this is a the spinal cord so
it's detached from the brain and what
will what you'll see happen is that the
leg will go over there and just wipe
wipe the skin you're on okay well that's
like a reflex that's simple enough but
you can start the limb from different
places and it always goes to that point
okay so now that's like completely
different muscle activation patterns
which means different motor neurons are
active and you can extrapolate that up
the chain and if I hold if I can
restrain the hind limb here then then
the front leg will go and wipe that spot
okay and then if you constrain both of
these then the leg from the other side
will come over and wipe that spot so
this is one of the things that I have I
just I don't I can't understand it
that the spinal cord knows what it's
supposed to do it has a goal and it can
do it very creatively
based on what what's available to it and
what its conditions are right so it has
to have knowledge of itself now so you
know somehow there's this abstract goal
that's encoded in the nervous system and
and there's lots of different ways that
you can generate that movement and I'll
just say that in general people in motor
control tend to study things that this
task level like they'll study reaching
and we hit the target or we don't hit
the target and we hit the target this
may times and it follows an optimal
control rule or Bayesian inference or
something like that and then the other
people tend to study well the left
deltoid went on and then the right
biceps and then we can describe these
very detailed patterns of movement but
where the magic occurs is where were
these things interact with either with
each other how do we go from here to
here I think is the challenging a
problem that that sits in the middle
here of that I think could use a
computational hint another example
quickly is you know here's a cockroach
and it doesn't even have a brain it's
very distributed processing and
generally when it walks these three legs
make a tripod and then it alternates at
the other three legs and then because
the I cook doesn't govern cockroach
experiments you can rip off the middle
two legs and you know and then then that
kind of it can't really walk but it
actually immediately changes gait
patterns to using the opposite legs okay
so I don't know how that decision is
made either but it's very clear that the
animal has motivation to run somewhere
whether it's going towards food or
escaping something else
I wouldn't call it learning I think it's
emergent it's just sort of and I don't
know if it's because there's no feedback
from the limbs or I just I don't know
but it doesn't really take time for that
to happen yeah I mean like if I put a
knee brace on you or you put on ski
boots it's not like you can't walk
anymore
right or if you get hurt you limp and so
we're able to rapidly change our
behaviors does it work like this when
we're not Spartacus
oh so you're saying in and it's natural
life does it do this it's it's possible
you know when you go over different
terrains or you might miss a step you
know that that these types of gate
changes are necessary so yeah it could
be it could be that it could be that it
needs to feel the ground before it'll
change gates or something like that okay
but these are so behaviors that I think
that are simple enough for us to
actually say are they successful or not
but they're still really challenging to
understand how that might might happen
and it's so challenging that I don't you
know we're getting to the point where we
can start to simulate these things I
don't know if you guys have tried QWOP
you can go over the web and try this
where you have you hit qw o p and you
try to make this thing run and the only
thing that it does is it changes the the
hip and the knee angles and this is the
the best one ever that somebody's
recorded I couldn't even get it to take
one step and like I studied biomechanics
[Laughter]
do some asymmetrical changes yeah so you
get different patterns so you can take
out one leg
yeah it'll it'll adjust yeah
and I'll say the cockroach system is
very distributed more just more
distributed than our system so there's
the ganglia and then that's like it head
ganglion and then stick insect which a
lot of people have studies even more
decentralized than a cockroach mainly
because it's really static whereas that
cockroach is very dynamic they you know
they're in your house but you can't see
them because they run so fast and they
said they might need more central
coordination between the legs but the
snick insects tend to be sort of more of
a peripheral coordination
all right so and so one of the reasons
it's hard is because our bodies like can
do lots of different things and so we
have to coordinate them very precisely
to do things that we want and it's
really not that easy to do this is just
a toy video we were just playing around
with trying to do some reinforcement
learning with a musculoskeletal model to
get it to walk and these are the
different iterations of reinforcement
learning algorithm where it can't stand
on and it falls and you know it knows
nothing about the fact that it's just
trying to go as far as possible and it
doesn't know anything about rhythmicity
or that it should be symmetric or
anything like that and so that's where
you know you can compare that - yep - to
physics like a baby learn to walk is
probably that uncoordinated
but over time you come that's right yeah
I do so we have innate patterns actually
have some stuff at the end but I'll just
tell you right now that that babies can
kick and actually the kicking in the
womb is actually very important for them
to establish the ability to do these
flexion and extension movements and when
they come out they have to learn how to
sit up then they have to learn how to
stand and then once they can do that
they can walk so they're trying--
they're actually reducing the degrees of
freedom of the body and in fact you can
see kids with cerebral palsy who haven't
that when they reach that they should
stabilize their body and and so they
they fall and then if you stabilize
their trunk then they're able to reach
so it's like how many degrees of freedom
can you coordinate at one time is is a
challenging problem for for movement and
and I mean we start with some bits and
then they have to get adapted to what
our current biology is so or my
environment right so if I got born on
Mars then would be slightly different
all right so so you know that's hard for
us to control a model to do simulations
of it walking
most of the biomechanical simulations
are not really simulations they're just
sort of recapitulation of what we
measured and I mean you can compare that
to Mike the headless chicken who is a
chicken you could go to Mike the
headless chicken org but you know
chickens running to put their heads cut
off this one actually was in the 40s and
lived for many years and grew and pecked
around and did all the things - chicken
- chicken doesn't have a very large
cortex but its behavioral repertoire was
in fact intact and so I'm gonna so why
how is that how does that happen that
which gets me to sort of a basic primer
on movement control and the hierarchical
systems that allow us to to move all
right and and the main idea is that we
have parallel pathways that allow us to
compute on increasingly abstract goals
to achieve movement so when I'm you know
you all walked here and I'm you you
weren't having to do co-op having to
think about when your ankle muscles went
on your toes and and things like that
and probably you're like on the phone or
texting and doing some very high-level
thing that your cortex should be doing
and not thinking about all the things
that you don't want to and in fact when
people have
nor did generate disorders or aging they
they lose the ability to walk and talk
at the same time so these things that we
shouldn't have to think about we end up
having to think about and that's one of
the indicators that somebody has it has
a proper balance problem
all right so this so broadly there are
you know when I teach the undergrads
were there three categories of movement
that we teach reflexive down the spinal
cord what we call automatic movements
walking breathing a lot of rhythmic
things which are largely regulated in
the brain stem and then voluntary
movement so all the things that you
actually want to think about doing and
and breathing and balance are
interesting because they're sometimes
automatic and sometimes voluntary at
some interaction of the two but the
take-home message is that all voluntary
movement requires this coordination of
all up and down the hierarchy of
movement and so I'll give you sort of an
example from my own research in
imbalance control is that the time
difference also matters so if I put you
on my platform here and we pull the rug
out from under you you're gonna fall
backwards it takes time for the signals
sensory signals to actually reach the
spinal cord even more to the brainstem
even more to the cortex so if you're
falling and and you want to respond
quickly then you can't wait for the
cortex to respond and and so when we do
the perturbations and we look at EMG so
this is electromyography it's an
electrical signal in the muscle which
directly reflects the activity of motor
neurons and Jeff Lichtman showed us very
nicely that there's one to one
organization between the motor neurons
and motor fibers and in fact the
neuromuscular Junction is the most
reliable synapse when the motor neuron
fires there is a vesicle released and
you get twitch in the muscle so my I
have this external indicator of what the
neurons are doing at least at the at the
output layer okay and and what we see is
that you know the complexity of the
muscle activity increases as time
increases because you
this loop happening and this loop
happening and that loop happening and so
you know you're in freefall 450
milliseconds which is an eternity for
you know like a robot and then at a
hundred milliseconds you start seeing
electrical activity that is really just
returning the joint back to where it
came from so it was very local variable
and that doesn't work for that long so
people with Parkinson's are very stiff
reflexes and and then they fall
backwards like a tree so at 100
milliseconds you start seeing a
different kind of a response which
actually as we call a balance correcting
response which you can't look at any
single joint and predict what it is and
it really has to do with what direction
is my body falling so that already we're
getting to what I would call more
abstract types of goal and there's many
different sets of cemetary and
information that could lead me to
believe that I'm falling to the left or
falling to the right and and it will
evoke I will show you later the similar
a motor pattern and then around 200
milliseconds is when if this isn't
working I might take a step and so I
might change my strategy or reach out my
arm or something like that so as as we
go to we basically have to you know
let's not follow the ground
well higher centers or you know are
figuring out what what we should do
question
cerebellum is important yes so the
cerebellum is very important for
movement and mostly we think about it
adapting movements from one instance to
the next so if I'm doing and there are
indications that if I give you the same
perturbation many times you're going to
change your response and that appears to
be cerebellar it's basically like when
you walk you take this ski boots off and
then you keep doing this and then it
sort of goes goes away you have all
these musculoskeletal sensors we also
have semicircular canals in the ear
balance detectors of some kind
yeah it turns out that I have removed
the vestibular system of certain animals
and this this early response stays and
actually the vestibular system is a tend
to act like our reference so if you tilt
the animal and then it doesn't get a
head signal we actually showed that they
throw themselves the wrong way because
they're missing the head movement signal
so for the very fastest ones we believe
that the these are proprioceptors from
the body from from muscle spindles and
and because they're in all the muscles
that you have to kind of interpret them
together there isn't any one signal
that's gonna tell you which way you're
falling but when that that system fails
people at least seem to have serious
balance yes they do
they have very a lot of difficulty
stabilizing their head and and all kinds
of things but we we think it's more
because you don't know well so here I'll
give you an example if if my vestibular
system gets a signal that I'm doing this
then you might say I'm falling forward
but let's say turn my head and now I'm
falling forward it has to be interpreted
in relationship to the position of my
body and so it's that integration that
is messed up rather than you know
the question back here sort of about the
cerebellum so you're saying it just to
clarify it's not part of this cycle that
you're studying um it's one it's hard to
know we basically have lesion studies or
patients to really tell us if we do know
that patients with cerebellar loss are
not able to adapt to their behaviors to
new situations and they also can't learn
their own dynamics very well so when I
move my shoulder joint then it causes a
torque at my elbow and we compensate for
that so I can do something like this and
people with cerebellar watch don't
and so this multi-joint coordination is
is really important for for balanced
control and so that is also another
reason that cerebellar the cerebellum is
important now I've also lesion
proprioceptive information from animals
and they tend to adopt behaviors that
look a lot like cerebellar patients
adopting a wide stance and things like
that and there's a lot of sensory
information that goes into cerebellum so
it's unclear whether it's the lack of
sensory information itself or whether
it's the processing of the sensory
information that can lead to sort of
this similar types of behavior so it's
hard to say exactly what what that is
all right so so this is what we learn in
you know basic motor physiology class is
that there is a muscle spindle in your
muscle that responds to stretching of
the muscle and that it projects mana
synaptically to the motor neuron and
acts like this feedback control system
where if I lengthen the muscle then the
muscle contracts and it shortens itself
so it's like a servo that's what people
say we we actually just had a paper
saying that the spindles encode force
which is often highly correlated with
length but it's it's actually quite
important in in the dynamics of the
firing rates and the timing that we get
for the the muscle spindles and and this
diagram is misleading because the the
same axon also projects to an inhibitory
neuron that sort of turns off the muscle
that's posing the movement so it's it
also projects to the other side it also
projects up to the next segment and also
projects all the way up to the thalamus
so we draw a very simplified pictures of
these sensory neurons that basically go
everywhere in our process that
information is processed in many
different ways at different levels and
ok so the stretch reflex we see gets
activated in the postural response there
are more complex spinal reflexes like
flexion withdrawal reflex if I step on a
tack and pick up my leg and extend the
other one and then depending on which
phase of gait I'm in the exact
activation of those muscles is going to
change okay so that's another example of
my spinal cord is really modulating
itself to achieve a task depending on my
current state and my desired state
and then here the the reflexes are then
modulated all the time so why did they
tell you to relax and when they hit this
is because if you do other things like
count or think or read or clench your
muscles it changes the amplitude of the
stretch reflex so we can usually usually
they get down regulated by cognitive
higher higher level tasks and in
diseases most neurological diseases they
go up and partly we think that the that
cortical system is is a has to inhibit a
lot of the circuitry in the spinal cord
so but this is our first line of defense
of just maintaining our postures
coordinating limbs to get away from bad
things and then for for walking you may
have heard of the spinal central pattern
generator which is intrinsic rhythmicity
we and with the in the in the spinal
cord now final pattern generators
existed a lot of different animals that
do eating breathing swimming rhythmic
things and in various animals they've
found single neurons that burst have an
intrinsic bursting rhythm pairs of
neurons with mutual inhibition that well
burst and while the mammalian spinal
cord also has this oscillation really
can't find it in the spinal cord and it
seems to be an emergent property of the
various interactions of inter neurons
and potentially motor neurons in in the
spinal cord and so what you do is you
you can take out the spinal cord of a
neonatal rat and bathe it in NMDA and
serotonin bath serotonin is really
important because it increases the
excitability of motor neurons so that's
what happens when you come out of sleep
paralysis is that serotonin chills
you know descends into your spinal cord
and instead and you don't act well
I would call it acting out your dreams
but when you when you move you you move
so the reason that you don't act out
your dreams when you're sleeping is is
because the serotonin system is often
your spinal cord alright so why why we
have this this this rhythm also is
extremely slow even though it's
oscillating so it needs sensory feedback
to make it through at the frequencies we
actually see during movement which is
why that interaction with the mechanical
system is important one of the nice
things about this organization is if you
if you look at the whole brain all the
way down to this spinal cord is there's
a region in the brainstem called the
mesencephalon look or motor region and
you can take an electrode and stimulate
there you can apply voltage there and
what happens is that projects down to
the spinal cord and activates these
rhythmic circuits and so it's like a
knob on the intensity of the frequency
of the oscillations and the spinal cord
that cause alternating flexion and
extension and so this is a nice tonic
level of activity that then gets
translated into rhythmic output in it
and it's one example of how then the
higher center can really just focus on
speed and not exactly which muscles they
should be activating and when which is
helpful for you walking and texting so
I'm going to show you a movie from the
20s maybe a little gruesome for some of
you that's a cat a d-separated cat so
they can live for a long time this is an
animal in a vegetative state but these
are very classic experiments done in the
20s by graham Brown and as a decerebrate
cat walking on a treadmill and you can
see that when you change the speed the
circuitry and the brainstem and the
nervous system can in fact adapt itself
to the speed and this is very vigorous
movement and
evidence that the the locomotor
apparatus lives below below the cortex
and people have taken this idea that
that you know if we wanted to interpret
what what these neural oscillators are
doing we have to embody them into the
dynamics of the body and the environment
alka apes fears built a robot that has a
bunch of coupled oscillators and it
changes the body's undulations from a
standing wave to a traveling wave
automatically when the when the thing
enters the water so that's like a really
interesting example of how we could
interpret what what these circuits are
for if we if we put them in their
natural they decerebrate 'add it so
which means that just took five minute
so actually the lines right here cut it
right here so what was left it depends
on where they they do it and I think if
you include what's called a mammillary
body that that is a little bit better
than if you get posture and you get
locomotion but all the cortices are gone
and the animals are able to live the
they were able to keep them alive for
four years and it's yeah I don't know I
don't know I don't think so and
certainly I don't think Mike the
headless chicken how to thalamus either
if you decide to go you had this line at
the bottom net spinal reflexes are
modulated by context adaptation emotion
movement and cognitive tasks yeah
so yeah the team spent fantastic to me
like I don't even know how to interpret
my own emotions but it's a my spinal
cord nose has prepared to interpret this
so it's just gonna ask like how does the
spinal cord learn how to deal with
this very rich cognitive stuff so I
think I'll show you in a minute their
project many many projections from
higher centers to the spinal cord so we
used to often think about the spinal
cord is a relay but I really think about
it as having a lot of different
abilities that need to be turned on and
off getting information that how'd you
get the right training signal to figure
out how to interpret this well I think a
lot of this is innate there is evidence
that the spinal cord can learn and
actually you can train yourself to
increase or decrease your your reflexes
and this is actually done as a therapy
for people with spinal cord injury and
and changes the excitability of the
neurons and allows people to walk better
[Music]
my spinal cord can will learn to
interpret emotions I wouldn't say learn
to interpret emotions but like emotions
are pretty fundamental like if you're
scared right then you're gonna tense up
they may be more reactive to to inputs
and I don't know that that's learned
that's something that can happen you're
right so the decerebrate cats will
exhibit what's called a sham rage you
can poke them and they get to get mad
but what happens is then they never have
it you ate to that right that you poke
them if you if you poke your cat over
and over and then it finally it's like
forget you I'm not responding to that
but if you do it to a do surrogate cat
then it just keeps keeps going so the
apparatus is there and it's it's a
combination of both the neural signals
but also a lot of hormonal signals and
neuromodulation as well so what I
wouldn't say that it's learned
necessarily
okay we're army so what does the cortex
do this is study from Trevor drew whoops
where we have an animal walking on a
treadmill and then an obstacle comes and
and here's the neuron that they're
recording from in the motor cortex of a
cat and the lower panels are the muscles
that are active okay so when the cat's
not stepping over an obstacle you can
see a little bit of firing in this in
this unit and when it's stepping over
the obstacle you can see that the firing
increases and then when it's no longer
stepping it it decreases again and you
have to think about the amount of time
it takes for the signal to go from the
cortex to the leg and so any muscle
activity preceding that is not caused by
the cortex and it looks maybe like this
activity could be this extra firing that
we see in this muscle to help the animal
step over the obstacle so it's sort of
adding to what is the nominal steady
state pattern that we see when when the
animal is is walking okay so and that
those are the things you want to pay
attention to right you're gonna walk and
then you might trip if you don't see
this step
all right and and we have to remember
that that this idea that the you know
they call them motor neurons upper motor
neurons in your textbook they actually
go lots of places so the pyramidal cells
layer five first of all the projections
from the cortex to motor neurons in the
spinal cord are mostly indirect and also
quite diffuse so Peter strick showed
through some anatomical studies that
there's this idea that there's what they
call old m1 so that the corticospinal
neurons actually project to inter
neurons in the spinal cord and then this
is also a bad drawing too because the
inter neurons project to multiple motor
neurons and then only in primates and
humans do you have this new m1 which is
part of the motor cortex that can
protect both inter neurons and motor
neurons okay so so there isn't really a
one-to-one between the cells and and the
motor cortex and the neurons down here
and I might say that actually they
should be orchestrating multiple muscles
if we want to actually do something
useful they also make pit stops they
have collaterals that can stop in
striatum the red nucleus and they're I
think the ridiculous final areas before
going to the spinal cord so it's
actually coordinating all of the
different levels of the hierarchy and
interestingly these areas like the red
nucleus is not that well understand but
it also has a motor map in it but it's
small and people don't really study it
so we don't know that much about they
don't say it anymore I'd say so so this
idea that you know this is your classic
homunculus picture representation of
what what the motor cortex does and it's
got a lot of hand areas and facial areas
and this
for manipulation and for speech and the
leg areas are quite small because as I
showed you most of the things we do
there are really to modulate more
automatic functions but this map is sort
of a fallacy it is not like only the
thumb gets activated here when you look
when you zoom in lots of different
muscles are activated there and it's a
very fractal type of of pattern and why
would that be so we there's ongoing
arguments about what the motor cortex
does and what it represents one very
intriguing study that I I liked is so
was done by Michael Graziano
which normally he puts electrodes in
France but this is a computational study
so normally we think about the hand and
leg and areas being sort of segregated
that's the cartoon picture and I should
told you that that's not actually true
they're really overlapping and so what
they did was a very simple study where
they observed what monkeys actually do
so they they reach and they feed and
they fight and they made a very simple
behavioral repertoire consisting of
zeros and ones of whether or not certain
joints were involved in particular
movements so are there things that
involve hand-eye coordination or
hand-foot coordination or reaching into
certain parts of space and then they
played this repertoire so they watched
the monkey for a day they played this
repertoire into a map that starts like
this this is a kohonen network and then
you know put in a simple rule of
minimizing the distance between neurons
that are firing together and what
emerges are these the hand shows up in
areas with the torso in the arm and in
areas other places with only the the leg
and a lot of these areas look a lot like
what what we see in in the neuron in
fact it had a two different frontal eye
field so different eye fields so you use
your eyes and in conjunction with
different
parts of the body and so this is a
behaviorally driven map for multi-joint
coordination possibly and you know if
you change the representation of
different behaviors then you actually
change the maps and that's consistent
with what we know about motor cortex
expanding and musicians who spend a lot
of time playing the piano and changing
and amputees who lose a limb and who
don't you know are no longer using that
body part so that the body that parts
for the representations for the other
areas will it will expand
mm-hmm oh sorry
I actually just copied that from their
abstract I was going to write kohonen
map and I said I better check that and
that that's what they they wrote so and
the other really intriguing finding
recently is that you can ablate the
motor cortex in a mouse and it can still
do most of the things that it has to do
and then solve etske did a study where
the analyst had to press a lever and
then wait 17 seconds and press it again
that before they would get a reward and
the animals actually would I think come
up with a bunch of superstitions like I
have to do this and scratch my head and
then something for 17 seconds to hit hit
the button so they come up these very
complex and stereotyped routines so they
can hit the button and get the reward
and they couldn't learn this when they
remove the motor cortex but if they had
learned it before and you remove the
motor cortex they could still do it just
fine so so now this idea of maybe the
motor cortex is sort of a tutor for four
movements and isn't actually performing
them but allowing you to assess assess
them and learn them and put put new
combinations of things together but I've
had an increasing number of people come
to me like maybe took out part of the
new motor cortex and nothing changed and
and you have to remember in rodents that
this is a thin smooth sheet so certainly
not as well developed as for for a
person and also mostly they are studying
reaching movements in rodents and I
think most of their cortex is for their
whiskers right so if the motor cortex is
training some other part of the variant
attribute these motor skills one of the
part of the plane with this information
recorded yes so remember there's lots of
maps all over motor maps and then
actually meant like colliculus is a map
of extrinsic space so it's not just in
in cortex and one of the things we do
know is that when when musicians are
learning to play the piano or whatever
their motor cortex is activated much
more than when things are well learned
because we ned's as a mystery where does
it that where does it go where you know
what's actually controlling the
movements and the other really
interesting thing is they can actually
if you're a musician you can practice
without moving your hands and then you
can get better too
that's a weird thing to talk about the
cerebellum but there would be a
candidate place where the over-learned
movement is true and I don't know enough
about the cerebellum to talk about it
you guys keep asking about it traces of
the original learning are from the motor
cortex being removed and then traces in
the hippocampus with all the learning I
I don't know that I'm this is not my
study or area so I would I don't think
they know either because these are just
behavioral studies where you're doing a
lesion and it's also it's very difficult
to interpret
liyan studies but they tell you the
necessity of something mostly because
they're also compensatory mechanisms and
so when you have a stroke you basically
often have a hole in your motor cortex
oh and if there's an ice league did this
that village has all the possible all
sorts of different Legion data and the
behavior results they use sort of
observe then anybody in here knows of
something like that no although we we we
had this discussion about how difficult
it is to get our data in some form that
somebody else can understand it and and
and this idea that every lab has got a
slightly different paradigm things that
they record lectures that use and and
it's really a problem in neuroscience
and in biomechanics we should mention
about the mice that when they lost their
cortex they remembered about the
superstitions just did the same hole do
you know if there was studies about the
fear response in that desolate cats
where like you could desensitize the cat
with that stay if you desensitize the
cat or would it still have the fear
response they were talking about uh
probably if you desensitize the animal
and then you remove the cortex it would
probably come back so a lot of the idea
about what the cortex is doing is
inhibiting the functions of lower
circuits so when when there are when
people have strokes and things like that
their spinal cords become hyperactive
okay
okay where were we oh good we're at the
end okay great so and so that's what I
mean by here so the the corticospinal
system is not just its coordinating
multiple levels of the hierarchy to
allow movement to happen and it's not
necessarily in control moment by moment
of what what is happening because it's
really slow but the fact that you have
this hierarchy means that you can think
the reason why we think walking is easy
right we actually don't have to think
about the hard part okay so how can we
understand this this amazing movement
and flexibility that that we have I'm
gonna talk about some of our research in
the neural mechanics and the issue of
modularity so it's just one aspect of
modularity a very first look very simple
idea so but again I studied balanced
control and just to convince you it's
there are lots of ways we can achieve
our balance whether it's taking a step
keeping our feet in place there's lots
of different ways we can move our body
to do that and in our paradigm we tend
to study people just standing there
keeping their feet in place although
we've had them stepping - so what what
happens is I look at the readouts of the
muscle activity when this when this
happens if I pull the platform backward
tonight I fall forwards and I have to
activate the muscles on the back of the
body and so this is just to show you
that the actually the stretch reflex
that happens at 50 milliseconds is
really small in in this particular
movement there are other perturbations
that have focused a little bit more and
then so the major activity is this brain
stem latency movement so it's an
automatic postural response you cannot
suppress it if you if I pushed you
I said don't don't respond you can't do
it you can
you sit okay so I can change the game of
it voluntarily but I can't change the
actual occurrence of the response it
depends on the experiment usually tell
them to try and keep their feet in place
yeah so there's probably something yeah
we can yeah and right so we can actually
perturb them strong enough sometimes
where they they have to take a step and
we tell tell them that's okay too
there's also a harness but nobody we
don't use that oh okay and so it then if
I perturb move the platform the other
direction then I get a different set of
muscles not completely but a different
set of muscles activated right and so
and as I said the evolution and
complexity of the response is going to
evolve over time
as the information gets processed more
and more and this is just to show you
that you're not just Co contracting all
the muscles is within 100 milliseconds
we the response is directionally
specific which means that multi-sensory
integration has happened and I know
which way I'm falling and then and then
what you do is you you can this is
looking down at the top of the person
and you can move in all different
directions and you can get these tuning
curves which there are scientists love
and so if I unwrap to this these
directions and put them on the bottom
you can see that there are some muscles
that are peeking in the backward
directions others in the forward
directions and none of them exactly the
same so we want to look at coordination
patterns across these or how complex of
the signals are there and you know how
can we understand the fact that for
every degree I'm gonna have a slightly
different pattern how does that does it
happen
so I usually talk to not math people so
this might be a little bit boring for
you but if we record three muscles let's
say that have three different tuning
curves we we used non-negative matrix
factorization to
to look at these patterns and infer sort
of the basis functions that might be
used to generate those patterns and so
what I might see is that you know if
there's a neuron that that responds to
rightward rightward leopard falling that
I want to then push right then I
wouldn't have to say okay what muscles
do I need to do that and so here we're
hypothesizing that there's this module
that encodes the relative excitation of
different motor neurons in my my spinal
cord so muscle one might be on a lot
muscle to none at all and muscle 3 about
half way and and what you'll see outside
is that you'll have a very strict
correlation between these two muscles
right and then well I'm a
three-dimensional person and so I might
also have a diagonal movement so if I
have another neuron that's sensitive to
backward Falls and where I need to push
forward I again I have the same set of
muscles to do the movement and so this
might activate you know we call it
muscle synergies or a motor module where
muscle one's a little bit muscle to a
lot and muscle three about half way and
so those might simultaneously activate
the muscles so so we know motor neurons
take lots of inputs from different
interneurons and hierarchical systems
and so you'll see the stricto activation
between the muscles and then when you
when you add them together then you get
you know the output that that we see but
the idea is that I can take these
modules which I call library of actions
and we can put them together
flexibly in different ways depending on
how much I'm falling to the right how
much I'm falling forward and I can now
construct movements based on on these
let's say these are learned actions so
I'm learning them as as I'm a baby I'm
learning how to kick my leg to the left
or to the right
question okay so so this was done
originally we did it and in the cat and
here these are the muscles that we
recorded from in the hind limb and here
are the sort of coordination patterns
that we saw that were tuned to the
direction of that we pushed them right
so this is a fixed sort of pattern and
then this says okay for each direction
that we pushed them how much was it
activated and then it was also able to
find a correlation to the output so I
was able to also decompose the forces
and say okay this set of this muscle
pattern then modulates the magnitude of
the downward force this one modulates
the amount of flexion force which which
happens in the opposite direction so
that leg comes up versus down and this
one is sort of forward direction and
this one is in the backward direction
and and if you look at the structure of
the musculoskeletal system it makes
sense that things are organized like
this and people have done some
prediction using energy optimization to
say like okay what's the most energy
efficient way for me to move my leg in a
particular direction and I might
segregate into these parts but also
notice that the same muscles are active
in multiple tasks so if I were just to
look at the activity of one muscle or
one motor neuron and try to infer what
behavior it was I would I would not be
able to do that so interestingly I said
oh well we can predict this with
energetic optimization but in fact we
see that each animal has a very specific
pattern that they use consistently over
multiple conditions so here's three
animals and the red bars are the muscles
that we measured in common we had
different implanted electrodes but you
know you might say well it's just this
is the module for standing up so you
need the extensor muscles that's a
biomechanical constraint they all have
the quads as the largest muscle okay but
this animal here doesn't really have
anything else on the
hamstrings are not on this one has a
little bit more and this one has all
their hamstrings on two so this is very
Co activated cat and I you know maybe
this one's more athletic and maybe this
one's more scared but even when we
placed them in different types of
perturbations and different
configurations that would have different
energetically optimal patterns they
reverted to these same patterns okay so
this this then can so convinced me that
this is a part part of the reason
convinced me that this was actually
something that was in the nervous system
and not something that's predetermined
by the biomechanics of the movement
because we try and change that as much
as possible and people have shown that
actually people prefer these habitual
solutions to movement rather than
optimal ones so usually that's what
people do is they minimize yeah yeah
that's sort of the standard thing in the
field to minimize the squared effort and
then the nice thing about the additive
parts of the non-negative matrix
factorization so if we're only adding
then if I have features in coordination
I can't subtract them so people always
ask me why I don't use principal
components well I if I have this pattern
it's there you can't erase it and one of
the things it reveals is that here's a
muscle this hamstring muscle I can
rather than saying it's correlated to
these other muscles 50% of the time I
can be much more I can make a stronger
statement which is that in in certain
directions this muscle is activated with
some other hamstrings and in the 270
directions it's definitely not activated
with them but Co activated with with an
extensor muscle so I can partition the
activity of
muscles here into two different actions
that involve two different coordination
patterns across muscles and it you know
we did this in humans too and and the
interesting thing is that again for each
person we get their own set of modules
and when you look at trial by trial
variability so if I give you two
perturbations in a row that are
identical the second one you'll will not
be as exciting you're not going to
respond as much they might have a really
strong response and then a smaller one
and we can decompose those responses now
by modulating these patterns so that so
the variability is not just noise it's
structured in variations of the command
to particular modules over the others
and if you average these two types of
behaviors like what I call hip strategy
sort hip strategy and an ankle strategy
it will get nonsense because they're
fundamentally different patterns of
muscle activation and so we don't we
don't like to average
and then the other thing that's
interesting is that you can then
generalize these actually this is kind
of a cute result that we saw that the
same similar modules were used in
balance and in walking which I wouldn't
necessarily have suspected except that
they're both these sort of subcortical
activities and so this generalization
across multiple tasks I think is very
important because once you learn to kick
a ball and and for soccer you want it to
transfer over to you know football or
kickball or whatever else you want to do
with your leg and in fact we we studied
that we studied ballet dancers for this
reason because we wanted to see you know
how they're able to achieve these tasks
and so you know you saw them walking on
the narrow beam and we showed that the
motor patterns that they use when
they're walking on the beam are very
similar to what they use over grounds we
call these shared modules and whereas
the novices are not able to do that but
if we put the novices in a easier
situation so over a wide beam and then
now they're actually using the same
motor pattern and and this is actually
counter to what the sports literature
says which is that you learn a skill
it's very specific to that movement what
we think is that you're taking so
walking's not very constrained so
there's lots of it like I said you were
all doing it differently is that then
I'm taking those modules and I'm
sculpting them so that they can expand
the range of tasks that they can do and
and by default that's going to change
the way that valley dancer walks and I
think that that's something that we all
intuitively can see that a ballet dancer
is different than a football player and
how they how they move he asked the
question back there
learned responses localize rated in
again in spawning is it muscle is right
have you been able to I studied the
humans the the one thing I can say is
that we did look at people with
Parkinson's disease and they're walking
and balance were different okay and
remember I said people can't walk and
talk at the same time and the ideas now
they're they're thinking about they're
walking after they went through
rehabilitation which was tango dancing
their their balance which is this
automatic response and they're walking
modules became more similar and so we
think that that meant that the control
of the walking was becoming more more
automatic in terms of patterns of
muscles and then we use them for
different functions that's right
activity absolutely I learned how to
study a new language and then I have an
another language and can can we have any
evidence that similar things is I think
funny cognitive functioning and not just
a massive functioning so I I do think so
and this is something I've been
interested in I haven't known how to do
it but I am gonna argue that you know
and also so speech is also a motor
pattern right and when we you know we
all have people of different accents and
in your native language when you project
that onto a different language you have
a very reliable accent so I think that's
a similar phenomenon that we're seeing
in ballet dancers when they walk and
football players when they walk I think
I took that slide off but I think that
these sort of ways that we learn to both
process sensory information and and move
are similar to the idea of cognitive
bias that when I am presented with a new
situation it's going to get filtered
through my experience and my my
expectations
but I if you'd like to talk about that
it's great because I don't know how else
to do it except by analogy so alright so
so there's some some work showing what I
talked about before the babies are born
with like two local motor modules and
then I get three and I'm gonna get four
as as they age so they did these studies
of toddlers and and children as as they
aged and so basically you know it takes
time for us to learn our bodies and
let's see this I'm getting and so so
this idea that we're gonna take these
modules that we have and refine them to
do other tasks
I call it backward compatibility I have
a task without many constraints and then
I want to generate basis functions that
can also do tasks with more constraints
and that's sort of consistent with the
idea that we're sharing these spinal
circuits across behaviors and and maybe
poses some constraints on but that types
of things that are easy for us to learn
or difficult for us to learn depending
on how you know how we started and you
know one of the things I don't know is
when do you need to develop a new module
when is it beneficial to do that or
necessary to do that enough times that
they became an expert like do you have
any idea of how long it takes to become
an expert i I don't know I don't like to
do training studies because it takes a
long time so anything that I do fights
with what what they do all the time
which is why as a first pass we're like
let's take the people we know are better
than the other people um and then but
but we did see evidence with the
Parkinson's patients after living with
the rehabilitation right so that was
three weeks intensive twenty two and a
half hours of tango dancing
and so this becomes very important and
when we're thinking about rehabilitation
and what pow'r trying to retrain brains
to move do you think there might be some
tasks that so you have to separate
individuals and one of them sort of
modifies an existing module to handle
the new task
maybe creates a completely separate
module sure so what I think I didn't
show you is that in different people we
see different numbers and I don't know
if that's just because the task wasn't
challenging enough I do know that my
student was on the Taekwondo team and we
saw a subset of people who like when we
pushed them they had this sort of
lowering the nice energy that we hadn't
seen in anybody else and and in their
Parkinson's to the idea is that when you
intentionally practice things that then
they can be actually changed your
automatic responses so I think we see
evidence of that we haven't studied at
any formal way to to really see that you
pretty much have to people who might go
through different learning processes but
they're sort of behavioral phenotypes
like what they do is exactly the same
but their module the structure of
modules is sort of yes pop yes probably
and I think that is gonna depend on
where they start and where they go and
it also has issues for practice so if
you think about there's a null space of
solutions right and it's for one task is
here and for another tasks it's here
where you are in that manifold and how
close it is to the intersection of the
two is is going to affect you know how
far you have to change it if it's close
you it might be easy but if it's far you
it might seem like a different task -
right right but I don't know I mean
these are things that I'd like to
explore computationally
alright so the motor modules and we're
just looking at the very output layer of
motor neurons is I think sort of a
control point to transform a very simple
goal right this is like the lowest level
goal of like movie your leg to the left
into muscle activity and and this is a
really cool paper by helix Jackson in
1889 where he said that just as many
chords musical expression and tunes can
be made out of a few notes you see these
re re re representations of movements at
different levels of the nervous system
okay and so I think that we're we're
seeing evidence of that and so I'm
thinking about this as a stored
repertoire of available motor actions
which allows very flexible motor
behavior and it actually allows you to
compute to actually not think about
biomechanics at all see where I am I
think I'm at the end and I so I'm not
going to go over this but like this is
sort of how I think about the system as
being symmetric and a lot of the things
we've talked about we are dealing with
interpreting sensory information but I
think there's sort of a symmetric system
going the other way but the information
is asymmetric so that makes it difficult
for us but what it means is that we can
think about abstract goals and then
implement them and biomechanics and I
have a whole bunch of work actually
showing that like that means that the
temporal signals activating these
spatial patterns of muscle activation
are also low dimensional but they're
related to the task so I'm gonna skip
over that right so we have this well
quickly a very simple model
this is stupid right inverted pendulum
and three feedback gains for the delay
and I can predict with fine accuracy
that the muscle activity that I see
across multiple muscles and it's related
to how the center of mass is moving
there's no sensor for the center of mass
that's my goal and it and it works even
if I'm have a very different sort of
biomechanical system so we didn't have
to change the gains or anything to do
with lateral movements
we were activating these muscle
synergies so that is a really crazy why
a dumb model like this actually can
describe a very complex behavior so low
dimensional adaptation and and so back
to this figure is just how we think
about information is going through the
the nervous system is that this
structure here for controlling multiple
muscles is recapitulated over and over
and over and the difference between the
spinal cord and the brain stem and the
cortex is how big it is and how many
different things how flexible how many
different things it can do so one how
how quickly you can change it not very
quickly in the spinal cord and then how
many different combinations you might be
able to to do
this one where he's variable
oh here here okay so what we can talk
about later but what all we did was we
said we have a pendulum we're going to
move it like our platform and then we
want to minimize the amount of effort
that's you the active activity squared
effort and then this is basically
performance so how far away from the
vertical so it's the state of the system
and then there's a terminal constraint
here to make sure you end up vertical I
might be Miss know the details in there
okay
so this was a trade-off between energy
and performance
so so basically I think these sort of
characteristic and constrained movements
and individuals sort of emerge from from
from the normal mechanical interactions
that make us all have our individual
patterns and I'm gonna go here this is
an interesting paper about modularity
facilitating sort of robust adaptation
and learning where you know you can
break things into subtasks this is
actually for visual visual identifying
pixels but there you can also look at
some generalization and across motor and
sensory systems when we talk about this
sort of modulate modulation fanning in
and and fanning out and so this way you
can change some of the network without
affecting all of the behaviors of the
network which i think is you don't want
to forget everything you want to be able
to modify pieces of the network so this
was a very intriguing paper to me and
where they were talking about adaptation
over generations but I think this also
applies for a lot of different time
scales and and one of the key things
that they did was they they included
connection costs remember I said neurons
are expensive and you don't want to have
projections where you don't need them so
I think the inner actually the
energetics of neural computation itself
is a is actually an important
consideration as well so what here this
is I'm gonna end with this my brain
computation wish list what do I want to
get out of this some improved ways for
us to look at our data so I think that
there are more motor modules than
muscles but right now we can only
extract fewer modules than the number of
muscles we record from if you think
about it I have n muscles even if they
just go on and off if 2 to the N
combinations
some are crappy which is why we have to
remember how we move right like like our
model it falls down most of the time and
so I'd like to explore some also maybe
some unsupervised learning of movement
patterns kinematics so maybe there it
seems that these subtle differences and
how we move actually do show up in
something that's recognizable to people
and as you're probably a ballet dancer
and you're probably a soccer player but
also you may have Parkinson's disease
and you may be depressed
there are movement signatures across
neurological and psychological
psychiatric disorders and in fact I go
to occasionally to neurology video club
where they literally record people on
their phones and older doctors train the
younger doctors oh no no that's not that
kind of a tick it's a different kind of
tick so there's information there and I
don't think we can label the data we
don't know what it is and so we I want
the data what the data tell us um
what's different I've talked to Gordon
Berman and Emery about he's been doing
with flies with Disney methods to
stochastic neighbor and Betty I can't
but he's been able to map out behavioral
spaces and animals so I'd like to
improve that some reinforcement learning
thing I showed you um but as I said I
think we need to embed some of the
principles that I told you that the
nervous system has which is learning
simple things we don't start with
walking learning simple things and and
then having different learning rates
across those those levels and and to
take into consideration dynamics right
so the time time matters and find one
thing I've been also interested in is
control theoretic approaches to
understanding you know changes the
relative costs and benefits of
changing my neural control versus
changing my biomechanical system so a
simple example if you've studied as
you're writing on it on a bus are you
gonna tense up your muscles or you're
just gonna take a foot and stand like
this when I model that system and I do
like a stability margin and using
classical control theory I can't
actually compare those two systems
because we always assume that the
mechanics is the same and so we've come
up with some also some very basic ways
to turn that into an eigenvalue analysis
which I don't have a student working on
but but I just said let's just can't we
talk about control mechanical control
versus neural control on the same with
the same metric basically so with that
here's some more food for thought
there's a book that came out this year
on neurobiology of motor control they
did a bear the editor actually edited
and they paired vertebrate and
invertebrate people so that we would
talk a little bit more about
generalization rather than very specific
system so that might be something that
we want to do in Chapter 12 is about
biomechanics the rest is neural control
and with that out thank you for your
attention
[Music]
[Applause]
very independent between or yeah it's
very bumpy we did some really silly just
trying to span the space of just pushing
and tried to really find the
characterize this stability versus cost
and it's an extremely bumpy space was
very hard to search the whole space
because there's so many minima all over
the place so we and we found that if we
had a low activation if you find the
minimum energy you want it's easy to to
move away from that into something else
that's slightly more stable but if
you're you've got a lot of high
activation it's very difficult to go to
low activation high activation is what
we see in patients actually but yeah
it's really hard to put it into any kind
of cost function or is it searching so
and that's another reason I think that
we have these individual differences is
because it's not easy to traverse the
space so if you find a solution that
works you'd want to stay there
[Applause]